former president Donald Trump has always
been Keen to put the focus on the many
buildings he owns but now he's being
accused of fraudulently misrepresenting
the value of those buildings and this is
the subject of a civil court case
announced Wednesday by the New York
attorney general
the allegation professional assessors
would decide how much the buildings were
worth but when the trumps went to get
loans or insurance policies they
dramatically inflated the amount in
order to pay less interest and get
cheaper premiums this conduct cannot be
brushed aside and dismissed as some sort
of good faith mistake
um the statements of financial condition
were greatly exaggerated grossly
inflated objectively false and therefore
fraudulent
and illegal
some examples his Club in Florida
Mar-A-Lago the likely worth was 75
million dollars but the trumps allege it
was worth 739 million 40 Wall Street in
Manhattan likely worth 220 million but
they put the value at 527 million and
Trump Park Avenue likely worth 84.5
million dollars alleged worth
135.9 million claiming you have money
that you do not have
does not amount to the art of the deal
it's the art of the steel
Trump responded to the allegations on
his social media site calling the
Attorney General racist and accusing her
of doing this to win an election writing
I never thought this case would be
brought until I saw her really bad poll
numbers she is a fraud who campaigned on
a get Trump platform but experts warned
these kinds of White Collar cases can be
hard to win you have to show that
there's intent a specific intent to
defraud and the lack of emails uh and uh
if there isn't somebody who will testify
against President Trump and say that he
had the intent to defraud that will be
something that he can certainly use in
his defense this is a civil case but the
attorney general has referred her
findings to jurisdictions that can bring
criminal charges and the Internal
Revenue Service she's asking a judge to
ban the defendants from being able to
work as an officer for any New York
companies for Life ban them from buying
commercial real estate or work with New
York banks for five years and she wants
the trumps to pay 2 250 million dollars
last month Trump had a chance to defend
the practice he pleaded the fifth so as
not to incriminate himself hundreds of
times now his lawyers will make the case
for a trial that could have huge
repercussions for the trumps and their
businesses Patty culhane Al Jazeera
Washington